a gente está vivendo numa sociedade de
código aberto
do jeito que a gente conheceu entendeu a
sociedade até hoje talvez esteja se
transformando e vou contar pra vocês
como que está acontecendo porque está
acontecendo e quais são os pilares
envolvido disso a minha base de
tecnologia de onde eu venho estudar e
sempre estudou a partir de dados
hoje o que a gente vê é que aquele
tratamento e aquela forma que a gente
aprendeu a usar dados pode levar poder
por outras pessoas e eu vou acabar
contando pra vocês aqui exatamente como
isso acontece
primeiro que eu vou explicar vai ser
como funciona essa história de dados
acontece que toda a sociedade hoje da
forma que a gente está vendo está
gerando muitos dados em todos lugares
nossos smartphones nossas relógios
nossas geladeiras nossos carros
tudo isso fica gerando dados o tempo
inteiro nossas redes sociais em qualquer
lugar
isso aumenta todos os dias nós olharmos
para trás
há pouco tempo atrás até 1970 a gente
gerava uma quantidade de dados que não
era nem captada e nem organizada né
hoje o momento que a gente vive é muito
diferente e essa quantidade de dados que
vem vem acontecendo
vem muito pela questão de uma troca
então a gente tem estudado muito isso e
tem vindo que tem essa nova sociedade
uma sociedade evoluída está disposta a
trocar um dado privado individual que
antes de gerava coisa genéricas por
coisas mais personalizadas
no momento que eu entrego mais nada ou
seja eu sou mais transparente momento
que eu sou mais transparente com as
minhas informações eu vou fazer uma
troca por produtos informações mais
personalizados
então é muito melhor abril o netflix lá
ele recomendar coisas mais adequadas à
china
as músicas que os cortes que discuta no
spotify já pensou se fosse selecionar
todas as músicas que quer escolher
então o algoritmo vai te ajudando sim
porque só trocando uma preferência
pessoal individual os teus dados permite
fazer algumas recomendações
só que isso não é uma coisa linear cada
dado que vocês a gente gera já outros
dados simultaneamente outros padrões
outras coisas e isso é o que a gente
enxerga entende como big data big data
como conceito é dividida em três pilares
está é velocidade e variedade e volume
vocês podem ver que as linhas apontam
para lugares diferentes aqui e elas
apontam para lugares diferentes
exatamente por isso que ele não é linear
esse crescimento dessas três vertentes
faz com que a gente tenha que encontrar
um jeito de estudar e organizar já que
uma pessoa pode estar falando algo
simultaneamente no mundo com que vocês
estão falando exatamente nesse momento
aqui publicando escrevendo dando o mesmo
número de passos que você subir o número
de escalas que vocês estão subindo
toda a cidade está em algum lugar
registrados né
quando a gente pensa no big data social
exatamente isso tá vocês com a sociedade
a gente com a sociedade está o tempo
todo gerando e deixando rastros é um
lugar em qualquer lugar que seja quando
a gente organiza essa informação embora
tudo dentro do mesmo pacote
o que acontece é que a gente começa a
fazer algumas descobertas e essas
descobertas hoje podem ser feitas em
tempo real quase como o monitoramento da
sociedade em tempo real de verdade a
gente inclusive tem um laboratório que
monitora em tempo real sociedad
o laboratório de big data social que
fica coletando todos os dados de
comportamento não olhando para o produto
não olhando para a marca
olhando pra hábito preferência gostos
tudo que as pessoas estão fazendo no dia
a dia ea gente quer coletando essa
informação para entender um pouco melhor
a sociedade de código aberto como é que
a gente faz isso a gente bota uma camada
de ciência ou seja a gente estuda a
sociedade em cima de não da nossa
percepção e sim de dados qualificados
usados e transformados em coisas visuais
existe um estudo um conceito chamado
sabedoria das multidões inclusive existe
um livro com esse nome que diz o
seguinte se eu tiver muita diversidade
de opiniões
isso foi descentralizado e independente
o que vai independência dessa informação
na hora que eu agrego tudo isso eu chego
a padrões de comportamento que eu vou
conseguir entender a sociedade de uma
forma mais exata e por esse motivo hoje
pode decodificar a sociedade
efetivamente ou seja recolhido dados ea
partir desses dados recolhidos já começa
a fazer uma decodificação de
comportamento
isso tem um processo
pego dado organiza qualifica e depois
começa a descobrir um código aberto
social
esse código aberto como se fosse um dna
tá onde eu tenho padrões de gostos do
que a pessoa gosta onde ela vive do que
ela vive como ela se veste que trabalha
lá tá
imaginem os rastros que vocês deixem
individualmente cruzados analisar junto
com toda a sociedade
e aí a gente vai começar a ver alguns
padrões a gente vai fazer algumas
descobertas
eu vou mostrar algumas coisas sobre
padrões comportamentais para vocês aqui
por exemplo eu posso afirmar para vocês
que todas as pessoas que estão em um
relacionamento sério na vida tem menos
relações sociais porque eu fazer essa
afirmação para vocês eu tenho andado em
tempo real os 60 milhões de brasileiros
todos os dias deixar algum rastro no
facebook todos os dias em tempo real
coleta organiza joga no gráfico
então o que vocês estão vendo o número
de interações das pessoas
versos um momento antes do relançamento
e depois vocês conseguem ver claramente
uma curva de um hábito de comportamento
das pessoas diminui o número de
interações a partir do momento que elas
estão em um relacionamento sério
a captura mas isso não quer dizer que as
pessoas são mais felizes né afinal
relacionamento uma coisa
axo né e se afirmar para vocês que eu
também posso
baseado no mesmo mostra em tempo real
que atualiza todo momento fazer
afirmação que as pessoas realmente são
mais felizes mesmo jeito uma linha de
sentimentalização mais feliz pra cima
mas feliz porque mais e menos feliz foi
baixo momento 10 reparei a curva do
crescimento aqui no momento que a pessoa
assume o relacionamento
as pessoas são mais positivas mais
alegres mais felizes a partir de um
relacionamento
isso são os dados de 60 milhões de
brasileiros atualizados em tempo real
é claro que algumas coisas chamam a
atenção quando ele começa a analisar
dados visualmente tipo só que ele dois
pontinhos lá em cima né
a gente quando estuda isso há a hora de
uma forma muito analítica mas quando
alguém de comportamento olha de só deve
ser uns virgem sei lá
bom há muito tempo atrás foi feito um
estudo sobre os graus de separação acho
que todo mundo ouviu falar isso hoje a
gente está num momento de de sociedade
com novas plataformas novas conexões que
quando a gente falava de 6.4 graus de
separação da sociedade
hoje isso diminuiu hoje ele está em má 3
graus e meio de separação de qualquer
pessoa no mundo
o mais legal é que antes eu não tinha
como fazer um teste disso
hoje eu posso testar eu posso fazer uma
média e ao mais do que entender que a
média de três pontos 57 eu posso ir lá e
fazer um teste comigo e com o meu time
por exemplo não consigo lavar eu tenho
um ponto três pontos e três de distância
de qualquer pessoa do mundo
aí os dados vocês podem fazer esse teste
isso é uma informação aberta à sociedade
está gerando dados mas também pode ter
um resultado disso vamos pensar um
hábito simples ouvir músicas dos
beattles pegar plataforma o spotify por
exemplo e o que significa isso
se eu pegar lá o que aperfeiçoar
só escutam de música virtual
especificamente eu vou pegar fazer
algumas descobertas tá bom
18 a 24 anos são 25% das pessoas 35 a 44
anos 16% das pessoas e 55 anos mais
somam 11% das pessoas até que não tem
nenhum padrão consigo ver um cruzamento
de dados mas não um padrão e se eu botar
o que essas pessoas escutam de música
reparem encontra em uma música igual
aqui dentro dos grupos
17 - 30 34 55 mais vocês não vão
encontrar o eu vou fazer mais uma
formação para vocês em cima dos dados
que é o seguinte se vocês olharem os
grupos do meio entre 17 e 30 anos e em
34 55 vôos estavam ver as músicas se
intercalando aqui a música que o grupo
mais escuta última que menos escutando
da mente
isso na prática significa que a gente
tem hábitos que se repetem dentro da
sociedade
tem pessoas exatamente os mesmos
comportamentos características e hábitos
do que a gente e que no final quando
está organizada a gente repara e
descobrir padrões do tipo
quando as pessoas vêem na internet hoje
né e que tipo de risada usam então vamos
lá
quinze por cento das pessoas riem 9
milhões dos brasileiros todos os dias na
internet usando quatro tipos de risada
hahaha o ré o e mogi e o lula
todos os dias a gente como é que eu
coloco isso uma ferramenta fica
coletando em tempo real o que as pessoas
estão usando
coletei essa informação vou organizar
ela mais pessoas usam hahahahaha
depois usam o monge depois vão reger
legal idade são dessas pessoas que idade
as pessoas têm as pessoas mais novas
usam o monge depois o rat depois o rei
depois logo vocês podem ver evolução de
idade
se você vai encontrar algumas risadas
que vocês usam
e você tá duas delas o rs rs rs e o kaká
eu tenho uma má notícia para vocês
elas são usadas por pessoas mais velhas
é por isso que não aparece no nosso
gráfico a que mulheres e homens então
mulheres usam mais e monges homens usam
mais raro
vocês viram que quando eu fui mostrando
pra você os gráficos visualmente ajudar
vocês a entender isso
então a informação quando tem alto
alcance contextual e auto autoexecução
visual ela se torna a sexy e atrai vocês
se ela não tem uma secção visual legal
ela é útil mas não necessariamente vai
ser sexo né
ela tem alto execução visual mais base
baixo alcance contextual ela vai ser só
age se não tiver nenhum dos dois é
inútil
dito isso vamos entender que não é só a
gente que tem acesso à informação todo
ano dados sociais públicos e se a gente
pegasse distribuir-se isso para a
sociedade
se a gente pegar todos esses dados que a
gente mesmo deixa coletasse organizar se
transformasse num local aberto para se
ver
talvez a gente estiver gerando poder não
é a construção de poder passa exatamente
por isso tá qualquer pessoa para ter uma
informação diferenciada um tipo de
conhecimento diferenciado já tem
capacidade de organizar dados
suficientes estruturar eles e
transformar informação quanto mais em
cima tiver da pirâmide de construção de
conhecimento sabedoria maior vai ser o
valor do dado
não adianta ter muitos dados
provavelmente não vai ter o valor muito
valor por isso têm uma capacidade de
organizar e qualificar e transformar
isso só a transformação do dado em algo
conectado simples e fácil de consumo vai
fazer com que isso tenha mais valor
o momento que ele está vivendo de
empoderamento social graças aos próprios
dados que a gente gera tá então quando a
gente pensa isso o que estou mostrando
pra vocês hoje é que dados quando
transformado em ciência viram um tipo de
inteligência visual que vai devolver
poder para a sociedade de alguma forma
seja em forma de conhecimento ou em
forma de conexões né gente
nesse momento chega num momento em que
na hora de distribuir esse poder do que
isso vai ficar na mão de poucos né
então a gente hoje tem no meio do
gráfico o verdadeiro playground que são
dashboards sistemas de informação em
tempo real que nos ajudam a entender
negócios e muito em breve vamos ajudar a
entender pessoas então empoderamento
acontece cada vez que a gente tem mais
abertura e transparência por parte dos
dados até que ele vai ter uma cultura e
visão analítica maior sobre as coisas a
gente vai aprender a usar isso
então a minha provocação hoje que a
mensagem que eu queria deixar aqui é que
a gente vai viver num futuro no mundo
cada vez mais analítico cada vez mais a
gente vai ver informações cada vez mais
a gente vai ver dados organizados
qualificados e no futuro cada vez mais
analítico porque a gente não pode ter
espaços abertos para a própria sociedade
ver dados analisar e entender o valor
individual para cada pessoa
o laboratório que eu mostrei pra você
voa no início ele é um laboratório
aberto a qualquer pessoa pode ir lá e
ver o comportamento em tempo real
a gente entende que aquele dado que as
próprias pessoas geram quando devolvido
para eles são valor
então o nosso papel é como sentido de
dados como pessoas de dados é coleta
informação beleza organiza qualifica mas
entrega para alguém que vá usar aquilo
de uma forma melhor que vai transformar
aquilo para o bem para mudar uma
sociedade quem sabe o mundo né
obrigado